a dangerous threat is spreading beneath  New York hiding in the shadows seizing  control of the underground regrouping in  a maze of deadly urban dungeons  we are this city's only hope a team  built to fight the unknown eliminating  our enemies and reaping great rewards  along the way and yet the rumors  continue terrifying whispers of the four  horsemen powerful cleaners hell bent on  learning out the virus once and for all  cleansing the city deeper purifying it  in ways no one could ever imagine we are  gonna end this madness it's time to gear  up it's time to take back the  underground  get all three major expansions and  exclusive bonuses with the season pass